hi guys in this video we're going to
talk about how to reverse wrinkles okay
as we age we get wrinkles
some people get wrinkles too early and
some people don't get them hardly at all
okay and I also want to talk about
collagen in general so taking your skin
from a rough kind of wrinkly skin and
bringing it to more of a youthful skin
what what controls that is something
called G a G it's a real long name you
don't need to know it but it's
glycosaminoglycans okay so it's a
chemical in your body that keeps the
skin in collagen hydrated electrically
hydrated it helps repair proteins and
collagen in your skin it also helps you
make healthy vibrant collagen and skin
alright and if you don't have this
everything kind of sags and droops and
gets hardened and it's not necessarily
the you know the sunlight over the years
that just makes your skin wrinkle in
fact the sunlight will give you about a
minute and protect the skin but it
really is a deficiency in this thing
right here as we age and also this is
responsible for your discs in your spine
to be really healthy and hydrated so if
you're shrinking as you're getting older
then we know you don't have enough of
this okay but you can't just take this
as a supplement and see the change
because what controls this hydrating
anti-wrinkle chemical is this thing
right here it's called IGF number1
insulin-like growth factor number one so
I'm going to talk about that it's a
hormone made by the liver that is kind
of controlled by growth hormone which
also is the anti-aging hormone so this
is kind of an extension off growth
hormone and some people actually take
growth hormone as a supplement to get
youthful but there's some side effects
to that so we don't want to take any
hormones we want to naturally figure out
how to trigger this thing right here and
I'm going to tell you the seven ways to
do it okay and it will improve your skin
greatly especially wrinkles okay number
one
this hormone teeter-totters with insulin
so if insulin is high this will be low
healthy young individuals need a hundred
times more concentrated igf than insulin
so if you have insulin resistance for
example or diabetes you're gonna have
higher insulin what will happen is this
will go down and people don't realize
that this is really important to
actually even help you reduce insulin
problems and even diabetes so so we want
to reduce insulin and how do we do that
well we change the diet and I'll put
some links down below you're going to
cut out the carbs you get your
intermittent fasting
you're gonna avoid the hidden things
that trigger insulin which is like MSG
monosodium glutamate there's a whole
bunch of things and I'll put a link down
below so we want to decrease insulin
number one number two we want to enhance
your sleep
whatever way you do it um you can use my
supplement at the sleep aid or some
other supplement but you need to fix the
reason why you can't sleep because
sleeping will increase this hormone as
well if you're getting by on five or six
hours of sleep you're gonna age quicker
okay so the sleep is important even if
you have to take a nap and then lowering
cortisol that's the stress hormone that
actually prevents you from sleeping and
it's just gonna this is coming from
stress so increase stress will decrease
your sleep and decrease this as well
stress will aid you right I'm gonna put
a link down below of some things to do
for that this is like your checklist to
look at okay so hi intense interval
training will also increase this hormone
I mean like amazingly so what we want to
do is we want to do full-body exercise
so there's a lot of different exercises
that you can do but you want involve as
many muscles as possible whether it's
you're doing a spin bike burpees
push-ups some bootcamp class
whatever it is you want to do this type
of exercise to do it high intensity very
short lots of rest not as frequent and
then every other day or every third day
make sure you don't over train but this
also will increase this this hormone and
growth hormone so it's going to make you
look more youthful moderate amount of
protein so if you think you're gonna add
more protein to help your wrinkles
that's not going to work you just want a
moderate
not too much because that'll stimulate
insulin how much is the right amount the
sweet spot is three to six ounces
personally I'm a 195-pound six foot two
I do five ounces of protein with each
meal okay it's a moderate amount of
quality protein not the soy protein
isolate crap you need high quality
grass-fed protein if you can get it or
at least organic okay next one is
enhanced the liver of course there's a
lot of things to this you know of course
avoiding alcohol alcohol will make you
age eat organic a lot of vegetables
maybe some supplements to support milk
thistle would be good dandelion root is
good for the liver things to improve the
liver because the liver makes IGF
number-one if you have a gut for example
we know you have a fatty liver so that's
going to be something your goal is to
get rid of the fat off the liver I'll
put a link down below of how to do that
but the main thing is getting off the
things that are stimulant insulin and
you can reverse that and there's other
things as well but next one is
intermittent fasting intermittent
fasting is is you eat a meal and then
you're not going to eat for a period of
time and then you can eat again like
you're not gonna have any snacks between
that meal there's more to this but the
point is that when you don't eat you're
stimulating growth hormone okay you're
stimulating this hormone this hormone is
activated when you're not eating
insulin is activated when you're eating
so insulin will deactivate this so the
more you do intermittent fasting the
more you're gonna enhance this and
you're gonna have to work harder as you
reach 50 years old in 60 and 70 because
your liver kind of becomes unmoor
healthy over time okay
intermittent fasting and the last one is
fat soluble vitamins
so that would be vitamin A vitamin D
vitamin k2 and all of that is enhanced
with certain types of healthy fats I
believe I demands so I get my fat Sabo
vitamins from egg yolks pasture-raised
organic egg yolks oh my gosh that will
give you all the fat side of vitamins
you need and you can also do cod liver
oil and you can do grass-fed butter
but again the fat size of vitamins are
really important into enhancing this
hormone to increase this all right hope
that helped so go ahead and do this and
and show us the results thanks for
watching
press it forget it forget it I'm done
press the subscribe button and I will
keep you updated on the future events